TO RUN PERSONAL ERRANDS.
BUT AT THIS POINT HE STILL HAS A
REPORT OF THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> Bret: KEVIN CORKE LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
WE HAVE NEWS FROM A FALL OUT IN
THE RELEASE OF THAT
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT.
HE WAS CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
>> AT LEAST TWO CAMPAIGN AIDES
HAVE PLEADED GUILTY TO THE
VIOLATION OF U.S. 182001.
THE REPORT ABOUT FBI PERSONNEL
DISMISSED THE IDEA THAT ANYONE
WOULD BE PROSECUTED FOR
MISLEADING INVESTIGATORS.
IN AN EFFECT ON MIKE
UNIDENTIFIED AGENT WE ROLLED
HILLARY CLINTON AID ABOUT ACCESS
TO SECURITY AT THE CLINTON HOME
KNOWN AS A SKIFF WHICH IS PROVEN
TO BE OFF CLEARANCE.
AGENT ONE, AWESOME.
LIED TO HIS BLANKET OFF.
WENT FROM NEVER ALONE LOOKING AT
THE SKIFF AT REST, TO REMOVING
THE TRASH TWICE COME TO
TROUBLESHOT THE FAX WITH HRC A
COUPLE TIMES, TO COME EVERY TIME
THERE WAS A SECURE FAX, I DID
WITH HRC.
RIDICULOUS.
IT WOULD BE FUNNY IF HE WAS THE
ONLY GUY CHARGED IN THIS DEAL.
EVEN IF HE SAID THE TRUTH AND
DIDN'T HAVE CLEARANCE WHEN
HANDLING THE SECURE FAX, NO ONE
WILL DO BLANK.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TAKES THIS
INSERTION.
>> THE FACT IS THAT NOTHING THAT
I SENT OR RECEIVED WAS MARKED
CLASSIFIED AND NOTHING HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO CONTRADICT THAT.
>> FOX NEWS FIRST REPORTED THAT
A HANDFUL OF CLINTON EMAILS
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED MARKINGS.
THE C STANDS WERE CONFIDENTIAL.
IN AN FBI INTERVIEW, CLINTON
REPEATEDLY SPECULATED WITH A
REFERENCE TO PARAGRAPHS RANK IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
WITNESSES TOLD THE IG PROCLAIMED
THAT SHE DID NOT UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE C MARKING
STRAINED CREDULITY.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
SPECTOR GENERAL ALSO REFERRED TO
FIVE FBI EMPLOYEES FOR
INVESTIGATION FOR POLITICALLY
CHARGED TEXTS REVEALING IN ITS
REPORT THAT MORE BUREAU
OFFICIALS BEYOND PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE EXCHANGED
ANTI-FROM TEXT MESSAGES.
AFTER A MONTH OF NEGOTIATIONS,
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO AVOID
ANSWERING QUESTIONS UNDER OATH
MUCH LONGER.
>> WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR PETER
STRZOK FOR QUITE SOME TIME NOW
AND WE HAVE ADVISED THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IF THEY DO NOT
PRODUCE HIM SHORTLY A SUBPOENA
WILL BE ISSUED BY ME, VERY
SHORTLY, TO REQUIRE HIM TO COME
IN AND TESTIFY.
>> ON MONDAY INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
14 AND DIRECTOR RAY WILL DEFEND